if you gradually build up your stamina
you can go a long way
and the same with language learning hi
there steve kaufman here
and today i want to talk about
language learning and entrepreneurship
and how they're connected
and i'll remind you if you enjoy these
videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and if you're on apple podcast please
don't hesitate to leave
a review there so you know for
much of my life i have been a guest an
entrepreneur and a learner of languages
so both are very much a part of me uh i
started out
as a canadian diplomat for seven years
but then for most of the remainder of
the period i either worked for a large
corporation or
starting in 1987 i started my own
company
in the wood business and of course 15
years ago
or so can't remember exactly
my son mark and i started link
so you know as i reflect back on this i
see some real connections between
entrepreneurship and language learning
the biggest connection is that both
require you
or and very much a part of both these
activities
is creating value and i can explain
what i mean by that now when we say
entrepreneur
it's a word at least the way i interpret
it it comes from
french from you know entrepreneur
entrepreneur
to undertake something to do something
and i think
doing something you know undertaking
something
being an entrepreneur is a big part of
being a human being we have ideas we
have enthusiasm we have curiosity
energy and we channel that into some
activity hopefully uh a useful activity
and where language learning and and
entrepreneurship come come together is
around this idea of value if you are
going to be a successful language
learner
you have to believe that learning a
language is valuable
and so many times i will sit there and
if i'm watching a movie that i can
understand or i
engage with someone in a language that i
have learned or i'm visiting that
country or i'm just sitting back with a
book
and sort of reaping the benefits of the
effort that i have put into learning
that language
i get a tremendous feeling of value this
is very
valuable to me when i'm learning
persian now as i'm doing and i learn
about the history of persia
and or even i follow current events in
iran
in the persian language in farsi
and then i i look up kuzestan which is
very much on the news now in iran and
i find out that it's a very rich area
with with
oil and water resources and farming and
so forth and so on all of this
brings me value my activity brings me
value but in the case of
language learning you're bringing value
to yourself
with entrepreneurship i think the key to
entrepreneurship
is to provide value to other people
only if you provide value to other
people are you going to be successful
other similarities are in my experience
when i started my own company in the
wood business in 1987
uh you know i had spent a long time
listening to people i worked for a large
corporation
i had spoken to many people in the
japanese wood business
i knew what certain people were looking
for
and what was not being provided by the
major
canadian or other foreign exporters to
the japanese market
so i had absorbed i had acquired a lot
of information by being patient
and then armed with that knowledge i was
able to put together
some you know supply and sizes that were
not otherwise
available in a quality that was not
otherwise available
i was able to provide something of value
to the market now
something else i think that's similar
between language learning
and uh and entrepreneurship is when you
start out
on your own and as i've done now twice
uh in the lumber business and then in
language learning
it's a long road and you have some
initial successes
but they can be almost sort of a mirage
because in both cases it takes a long
time it takes a long time to
build up to that point where say in the
case of languages you're getting that
value that enjoyment
you know it's like um i don't know it's
almost like it's a long distance run
it's uh you know here in vancouver we
have a thing called the grouse
grind which is somewhat less than an
hour climbing up a very steep
mountain if you start too quickly you're
going to burn yourself out
if you're going to be in a long distance
race and you start too quickly you run
out of gas
and whereas if you gradually build up
your
stamina you can go a long way and the
same with language learning
it's not what you can do in the first
little while that matters is
what you can do you know at the end of
the journey or later on in the journey
and the same is true the companies i
mean whether it be link or whether it be
my wood business it was a long road
before we started to get
any traction we had some initial
successes
but that wasn't enough to make these
ventures viable
we had to stay with it stay with it long
enough
for it to finally mature
another thing about entrepreneurship
which i firmly believe
is that you know obviously you have to
give value so it begins with giving
you can't begin by taking you begin by
giving
and you also have to be in most cases
this is not always the case but i think
largely you have to be a manner for a
woman
of your word if you say you're going to
do something you have to
do it you actually have to deliver
in entrepreneurship so that people will
trust you
and that means obviously knowing your
business
not committing to do things that you
can't do
uh being honest and so forth and so on
and staying with it
and i think language learning is the
same way you have to be honest with
yourself you can't tell yourself that
you're better than you are or criticize
yourself
for being worse than you are you just
have to stay the course
honestly and eventually you will
reap the rewards and the same i have
always found in business if you are
honest
with your counterparts in terms of what
you can do
without overstating what you can do but
also not
doubting that you can do it in other
words you have to have the confidence
that you can do it
without overstating what you can do on
that basis you will
in time because it doesn't happen
overnight and if it's based on your
knowledge knowledge of the market
knowledge of products eventually
knowledge of people
you will build up the contacts the
credibility and so forth
and similarly in language learning if
you give yourself credit
for what you have achieved don't
overstate what you can do
you will find that you will gain more
and more confidence
and eventually you will be able to you
know reap the rewards of those efforts
so
i wanted to mention that today because i
think uh i might just over
you know in the next little while in
these videos talk a bit about my
experience
as an entrepreneur things that have
worked for me
uh i don't know if that would be of
interest to
you out there i'm also going to be
talking in different languages
i haven't done that for a while because
i think most people probably understand
english not certain that they all
understand these other languages if i do
speak in other languages
we will make sure they are translated uh
when i speak in english of course the
video and the audio and the text are
uploaded to link as
lessons i we have had a policy at link
that we really only want native speaker
content
uh in our library so if i speak in
another language i'm obviously not a
native speaker
i'm not sure it's appropriate to have
that as content in our libraries
but at any rate uh that's kind of a kick
off to this idea of talking a little bit
more about entrepreneurship
as it connects to languages or even
without any particular
connection to languages so i'll be
interested in hearing
from you what you think of this idea
so thank you for listening bye for now